Now we're going to spend some time building cat clicker together with Knockout.
You can find the files I'm using at the repository linked in
the instructor notes.
Now, here's our out index.html file, but
we're going to put that aside and open up app.js.
As you can see, we're starting with absolutely nothing here.
First, let's make a ViewModel so we have a place to put things.
Now, if we only type this, nothing special will happen.
We'll just end up with a function called ViewModel, but it won't ever get run.
We need to tell Knockout to apply our bindings to this ViewNodel.
Now, I'll go over what that means in more detail a little bit later.
For now, let's just start our app by typing ko.applyBindings and
a new ViewModel.
Now let's hop over to our browser, hit refresh, and
ensure that nothing pops up in my console.
When I'm developing, I go back and
forth a lot to make sure I don't run into errors.
Now let's go back to our app.
We need to put something inside our ViewModel here.
For now, I'm actually going to put our model here in the ViewModel.
Now, this may seem confusing at first.
You may think, but Ben, aren't we supposed to separate things?
Well, the most important thing for
now is that the pieces are functionally separate.
For simplicity in this example,
we'll define our model stuff here inside the ViewModel.
But even though the model is being defined inside the ViewModel,
the functionality is separate.
Now, in a few lessons, we'll see a good way to separate out our model data
more cleanly, but for now, we'll go with this.
So, what do we need in here?
Well, we need the same fields as before, name, click count,
image source, and, because we appreciate our artists, image attribution.
And there's our model for a simple version of cat clicker.
Now, what about our ViewModel?
We obviously need an incrementCounter function.
But if we look back at our previous code from the last lesson,
you'll notice we don't need most of the functions we wrote before.
For example, before, we had a getCurrentCat function,
which allowed the view to get it from the octopus to get it from the model.
We don't need that anymore because Knockout will handle the view to model and
model to view synchronization for us.
The only time we need to write ViewModel methods are when we
need to actually change something ourselves.
In this case,
this.incrementCounter is going to set the clickCount to be itself plus 1.
As you can see,
this.clickCount with nothing in the method is getting our clickCount.
We're adding 1 and then taking this whole thing here and
storing it inside of this.clickCount.
Effectively, what we've done here is say count plus plus.
In this case, it's this.clickCount, and
this.clickCount is a Knockout observable.
Now all we need to do is make our HTML connect up with this.